the church what's happening now I would
love to send its heart out to El Paso
and Dayton Ohio we're very sorry for
your losses and what happened there this
weekend greetings from podcast ville the
Church of what's happening now is
brought to you by hymns
listen summertime is here why the hell
are you breaking up the baseball cap for
the day at a beach or a ball park if
you're wearing it to hide your thinning
hair you may not have to anymore
don't sweat hair loss this summer do
something now while you still can
listen 66% of men lose their hair by the
age of 35 why do guys turn to weird
solutions or do nothing when they could
turn to medicine and science for hems
calm is a one-stop shop for hair loss
skin care and sexual wellness for men
and right now the church family gets a
trial month of hymns for 5 hours Joey
what are you talking about 5 hours 5
hours right now while supplies last see
the website for full details and safety
information this is gonna save you
hundreds of dollars it would cost you
hundreds of dollars if you went to a
doctor or pharmacy uncle Joey's here to
save the day go to for hims com
slash Joey that's for hims fo r hims com
slash Joey for hims comm slash Joey the
church is also brought to you by zip
recruit it you have any idea hard to
find the good employees unless you want
to work at Subway do you have any idea
how hard it is to find a good employee
no you don't hiring is challenging but
there's one place you could go hi we're
hiring is simple fast and smart a place
where growing businesses connect to
qualified candidates that place is
called zip recruiter dot-com / search
zip recruiter sends your job to over a
hundred of the web's leading job boards
but they don't stop there with their
powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and invites them to apply for your job
and right now today right now the church
family gets zip recruiter for free
you're like Joey
what are you talking about free that's
what I'm talking about free at this
exclusive app dress zip recruiter calm
slash Church CH you are CH that zipper
crooner dot-com slash Church a smarter
way the higher take this [__]
merely listen I got a thousand [__]
names in my head a de Lautrec is
Gonzales you know me though I love that
song you every time I come you play a
classic I'd [__] you think you're
dealing with joy but Alice last time a
little Spanish music is good for the
[__] soul yeah last time it was a it
was with the Panamanians name that was
part of the all-stars Freddie Mercury I
don't [__] enough you know I listen to a
lot of [__] you don't man I
don't know what I listen to how are you
I'm great how you doing good I like the
glasses look at you I like the sir
[__] badass but every machete
representing the Pittsburgh Pirates game
this is [__] Clemente's uh and it's
funny a lot of [__] since I wore this
sure this happened in Puerto Rico I warn
our audience the first time and also my
world got flipped upside Oh Matt sort of
getting emails to make videos and wear
this shirt and solidarity to get the
[__] governor I beat you got caught
on tape talking [__] and [__] same
[__] write down the Governor of Puerto
Rico I didn't bring him down but took
his chat room somebody brought him down
he kept saying I'm not gonna leave yeah
I got the goon squad coming in from the
Bronx no date that [__] they
made this as resign and nothing I throw
his after off the [__] island and
then the governor that wanted to replace
them she didn't want it she's like these
[__] ain't [__] around
please those governors are feeling like
a Kennedy right now they walk around
with helmets the space suits on and [__]
it's tough being a [__] like
motivational Puerto Rico oh my god
I don't give a [__] down there PR they
don't you saw it what happened to that I
get thrown artists they shot him in the
head cuz he was threatening to release a
video about another artist being gay
and they took care of him which is
horrible I was so poppy doing
nobody copy yeah he's out of the
hospital now but yeah the Dominican
Republic was it wasn't like 40 people or
something crazy like yeah he was mad it
was who is he messing with he was
messing with a cartel person know who
papi but yeah that's what they said he
was messing around with somebody's wife
and they had they put a hit out on him
so what does all this stuff make you
guys feel like like Cuba has its own
issues but it's still home like do you
guys like is it weird for you to be like
okay it's probably not safe to go there
right now like I don't ever feel not
safe around my people I can go anywhere
in in the Caribbean the Latin speaking
Caribbean and I'm not gonna feel unsafe
okay I'll go to Puerto Rico out or to
Cuba what people don't know is Puerto
Rico over the years has had a decline
like I used to go to Puerto Rico every
year for Christmas pretty much till
nineteen something like that my mother
died yeah they said the crime the crime
rate is it is unbelievable I mean uh six
eight months ago one weekend in Puerto
Rico they shot as many people as they
did in Chicago yeah you know they're
saying that if you're a tourist you have
to stay and dwell some wanna keep it
light now you know you go off those
roads bro
there's people posing with that car
[__] broken and a hot chick with a
bikini you go to [__] fix a flat ten
Puerto Ricans jump out of a bush snitch
in there with a pipe and it's like that
you just can't say Puerto Rico it's like
that honey listen yeah I went to New
York few weeks of months ago to spend a
shitty movie mm-hmm and I'd walk around
those touristy areas and I'm like these
people are dead giveaway
mmm-hmm like just way you stopping and
how you looking you're looking up at the
buildings and looking up at the
buildings were looking at your [__]
soul you know so they stick out I
remember the seventies in New York
tourists would get lit up lit up Miami
zoo I never forget seeing a family get
all their money taken
playing three-card Monte oh yeah that
day is still etched in my brain forever
that we what you know I do where people
understand this three-card Monte is
three cards on a milk crate upside down
with like a velour sheet and this guy's
hustling in he's got three or four
lookouts and you're trying to find the
red card or the black card whatever it
is and he's shuffling he's a street
magician guys these guys are gypsies yep
and I'll never forget being in the 8th
grade freshman year and going over there
with a kid who's dead now the fact that
was his anniversary August 3rd of dying
39 years Dominic's wish y'all got
restless soul and I knew that I saw the
family and they always have one guy who
they left with yeah so you watch the guy
win and you're like I could do it and
I'm losing 20 bucks and after I lost my
20 bucks my buddy started yelling at me
and to make a long story short he
through with his money after yelled at
me and he lost but there was a family
there from Germany or Europe somewhere
and I'll tell you what man they were
[__] they lost everything leave when
I tell you there was a stack of
traveler's checks and when that guy and
once they make a big hole they go police
and they flip the milk crate up and they
just disappeared yep and I'll never
forget the look on this family's face
like don't they
if I never forgot it it didn't happen to
me and I never forgot they just stood
there like dad the four kids the two
kids holding his wife and they were the
wife of the husband would just look at
you like what just happened like what
just [__] happened we just lost our
vacation money in six minutes in six or
seven minutes and it was just like god
police and the thing went up and there
was no cops and the guy kept saying
where you going where you going I want
to win back my money and they're like
the cops dog and they just started
running and that was the end of that
yeah you know in Miami though when I was
growing up in the 80s the thing there
was a time in a period of the 80
where they would look for the rental
cars that to see the rental cars
yeah smash-and-grab they were smart and
now they said they're starting to do it
again and they smashed the windows and
then they take whatever out of the car
but then people fighting them for the
car so people get shot and they get
killed and it's really really it's
pretty sad you got to be on guard people
are the the thing is that this has
gotten so crazy with the haves having so
much and the poor people everywhere they
lose in their minds and that's what
happens when people are struggling and
hungry they start stealing well living
in weird times Dana yeah I mean we're
living in
you know we this country had a weekend
this last weekend it's traumatizing my
like I said the beginning of the part
are cast my heart goes out they'll Paso
and Dayton to places where I you know I
cut my comedy teeth El Paso yeah I mean
I was in El Paso he used to bond me two
weeks of the shot that guy Bart Bart
yeah you know my heart goes out to
Patrick and Larry and his family done
there's a lot of guys with down that
aisle him not I got ahold of the guy
that used to work with Gabriel's website
is down there yeah I mean I've been
thinking about these people all weekend
Dayton a lot of these times I played
that finding volleyball yeah the funny
bone in Dayton was the first club to
headline me after I did Last Comic
Standing really yeah I was and I had
such a great experience at that Club it
was great I just I go to Cleveland
Columbus but I gotta make it back to
Dayton especially now but you so what
you're trying to tell me is I can't go
to a Garlic Festival man you can't go to
Walmart now I gotta keep my eyes open in
the movie theater I gotta keep my eyes
open at the [__] country concert being
outside at any concert yeah you know so
I mean that bar was down the street from
where I live now the one in Thousand
Oaks I live in Woodland Hills that's
right and one of our comedians Courtney
Sherman she's to hang out at that bar
that bar that got shot up by that guy
what about last week with a guy in Van
Nuys the guy who killed his girlfriend
and her entire family over here yeah my
wife said she was driving they call
the street by the barbecue place on
violin and then it's on violin there but
you know this has to offer I mean I'm a
micro type of dude like I've always been
a micro type of dude that's one of my
shortcomings in life listen I love to
worry about the whales and I love to
save yeah I'm [__] white kid in
Africa but guess what I have friends
that I have a hard time I have friends
that can't put their kids through
college now I have homeless people in my
[__] neighborhood and I take care of
that I'm gonna have a lot of food I'll
go out and hunt them down
I've always believed to be a micro type
person you know what that's great that
they found the wolf in Africa I'd love
to do with me and my ability to get up
in the morning and make my life happen
this last weekend really makes you think
outside the box and you go what what's
the like I hate that [__] target on
victory really oh I [__] hate that
that place is just scary Victory
Boulevard here in the valley to invite
my wife yesterday no more with the baby
up there yeah she even said she goes I
don't like it up there either I'm not
gonna fire that whole foot book that
they had one time they had that whole
soccer field covered with women doing
Zumba you can hear them inside [__]
target the speakers that has another do
it's just a fucked-up neighborhood that
I don't like but we're living in a
society now like I told my wife i sat
them both down list better I set them
both down
you know I said listen bad haha your
[__] mother Aish Terry but my mother
raised me look straight the [__] ahead I
go when you go off you know I don't want
to see that [__] folder that's right
I don't want to see that photo it's too
late to conduct business you know it's -
you gotta be looking when you walk into
a place now you have to look for the
exit sign that's right to see where you
stand
put that [__] phone away I'm not
gonna [__] tell you again ladies and
gentlemen put that [__] phone away
yeah as soon as you getting you walked
out of your door
put that [__] phone away that phone
ain't doing nothing for you that's why I
don't want no text that's why I don't
like when people text I don't even
answer you back I just say erase it
I'll even read it that you don't respond
to them don't respond and people should
know better yeah
if you're that if you're that stupid and
you're gonna continue to send me text my
hands I can't do business I'm glad you
told me
oh no that's our figure but I don't like
texting I like I just met acht
if you text message a person to twice 9
and he don't call you back and you
continue to Texan I can't do business
here that [__] you can't read the
cues pick up the [__] phone and call
you don't know how many times I'll go
back and forth with somebody 10 phone
calls and then they'll send the tax and
those 10 phone calls all went away
because we've been talking for three
weeks now you want to send me attacks
done god sweetie though yeah I don't
like really though that's how I was in
Chicago this weekend I was working as a
knees and I was staying in that area
right and the lady that worked there was
like let me tell you something she said
were you walking down the street make
sure you're not on your phone she said
somebody will push you in the bushes and
take your phone from you and lord knows
what happens she's white and she said
and if you think that they're black but
it just Latinos you out of your mind she
said everybody has lost their minds in
the city they told me you think that
people are just getting shot on the
south side she said my [__] are
getting shot all over this city and
don't you think that is just black
people she said you better stay on guard
and I was like damn like that was my
welcome to the weekend club because she
was like you a woman take downtown all
weekend yeah she was like you a woman
and you by yourself and I nobody's gonna
tell you this but she's like i'ma tell
you she said when you're walking around
you going to your room we pay attention
to everything around you she said they
have all lost airmen we have to go back
to basics yeah as an American now 240
shootings this year something like that
to watch more shootings and days that
we've had in the year in a year I mean
that there's more shootings than there
have been ufc's they've been in business
for 20 [__] years so I'm in one year
we have to reap
I mean and then you could sit here and
talk political rhetoric from whatever
say it again I don't even know where to
start with this no cuz there's a problem
it's like prohibition you try to get all
the guns out you don't know where to
start
they're gonna if you get the guns out
then the prices go up in the black
market increases and then you're gonna
get stronger I mean you don't even know
where to start yeah it's like the
homeless problem yeah right now if you
[__] pull out of here and head to the
101 to head south there's a guy that set
up like a [__] circus
yeah they got an encounter you gotta see
this guy he's got a three he's got a
circus over there he's got a dog a
little sheep a little pony now I'm not a
[__] governor I'm not a [__]
college graduate but I know that guy is
not homeless that's a mental health
issue that's right there's a big
difference between mental health and Lee
coming to me when laying on I can't
afford the rent no more that's right I'm
moving out and I'm gonna take my chances
and take showers at the Y and go on the
road and if not just stay in my car this
is a big difference that's fine between
homelessness when you go downtown
there's three I categorize in this just
33 and 1/3 that really are hard on their
luck oh yeah that just need to
reorganize a shelter a halfway house and
sorts to get them on the right path a
job shower yeah and then you have mental
health people that they don't want you
help so what we could do is reach out to
them give them medication shoot them
with vaccines and let them live in the
[__] weeds that's if you want to
pitch a tent under the 101 and you think
that's happiness
what the [__] am I to stop you weather
where the people don't realize is like
those fires that happened when it was
cold
it was the homeless people that were
cold in the woods and they said the
woods on fire too they built fires and
then people's houses burnt down so
that's how it all affects everybody like
when you say that's not my problem
but you're Ellen's house was burnt down
like it is all of it is connected at
some point a black dude my bodyguard I
call my bodyguard
the vet from Iraq lack of he's got
dreads knees six before to wait he you
know the guy I'm talking about I tried
to hook him up like three days a week I
see him and I'll make a u-turn on give
him a twenty so he can eat something you
know that's my way out but night but
from conversations I've had with him
he's not homeless
he's got mental health a shine he's got
african-american mental health issues
you know he's not an angry guy he lives
from the VC's my daughter he waves
hmm he just rather live in a [__]
park then deal with [__] society he's
never asked me for a dime but you know
what drives me crazy he never asked me
for a meal I'll see him but that's what
I'm gonna tell my wife if you see him
pull over let him see the baby and give
him a twenty so if he's in the
neighborhood and there's a shooting he
just wakes the [__] little white kid
in half because that's why God sent him
into a wall I once said that black dude
at the Walmart at first he would have
got that little [__] he got that
little speck hater and broke his [__]
neck right in there this guy you could
shoot me ain't going down he's like
Young Frankenstein I watched Peter Boyle
and Young Frankenstein they were
shooting that [__] if you go
down that bad guys not going down I
think he's been shot like 18 times he's
been shot more than Tupac and LeBron and
all the rest of these [__] half-wits
that dude's a real deal you know it's
funny though I was thinking about is
like you see all these people always
they're Patriots and they love the RET
the veterans but a lot of those homeless
people are veterans and nobody took care
of and if you ever I go to the VA s to
do comedy and volunteer is horrible
those VA hospitals know
bendito like I feel I'm like man are we
treating the people that have gone to
combat for us like that yes bad I think
that somebody goes to war for us
somebody goes somebody leaves our
country to go step on foreign soil for
us I think they have the right to be
taken care of that's what I feel I feel
I feel that they should so as they come
back here they should not be expected to
work if anybody has seen a car accident
you know how you get affected by it
never mind it's like that
police chief yes say no pass no said you
know he never knew there was gonna be an
odor of blood the blood has an odor you
know what do you expect those people
that come back from Vietnam and Iraq and
all these wars that we've got into when
you come back you can't cope yep you
can't cope it's a heavy dose you know
hearing gunfire could change most people
yeah did you know that like just hearing
what those people went through with that
Walmart the other day or in Dayton or
whether you got shot or not just being
involved that's gonna affect you direst
of your life absolutely you know not
gonna affect you there's gonna be a
phobia in this country call like a
shooters something yeah they're gonna
come up with a name and I love what a
name for it because it does affect you
that's why you say you don't have a you
didn't go to college and you're not we
need somebody like you to be a
politician you're the kind of person
that we need an office that will because
of that practicality that we need all
the politics that we've had that's all
about checks is people getting checks
from this company and that we need
somebody like you we need somebody who
thinks like you and say let's find some
solutions for the people I wish I had
the capability like I wish to turn
because why would you get them it's like
I got a big problem with nonprofit
organizations I have a very big problem
with nonprofit organizations I have I
want to help people but I have a hard
time writing a check because watch the
CEO that nonprofit have a better car
than I do if I'm donating to you why
should the CEO and the assistant CEO and
the [__] the operators manager have a
better car than I have if you want to be
help people there's a basic salary cap
it's $48,000 a year yeah but that's not
you wanted to help people that's right
you wanted to be Johnny nonprofit right
so now figure it out if you want to be
make money then there's business
you want that's why I have a hard time
donating to a [__] company I'm not
ashamed I'll donate to Chris Herren
because I know that my that [__] goes
directly to drug people that dude
doesn't have an insincere bone in his
[__] body but anybody else have a lot
of hard time yeah I rather hand you the
money [__] direct that's right I'd
rather hand you the money direct so I
know that nobody's taking you know when
people call you know like hey we're
accepting donations for these policemen
benevolently by law those people only
supposed to donate like twenty-eight
percent they're allowed to keep the rest
I don't don't quote me on the percentage
but Destin if you really look into it
you're being shot you vote so wait a
second Joey I get up every [__] day
to go to work and I donated a thousand
bucks for the Police Benevolent system
and they're only gonna get to lady out
of it that's right I'm gonna get some
[__] fat [__] like me it's gonna be
in an office smoking a cigar
telling people he's gonna go ride his
boat on a weekend none on my [__]
dime none of my [__] die yeah when
9/11 happened remember they were doing
those big fundraisers on NBC and they
had all that money there were 12 black
firefighters whose families didn't get
any money from none of that money so
like they did a fundraiser and we did a
fundraiser and to help those kids
because they all lost their fathers and
they never got any money so they were
like some of them were like struggling
to the point where they were gonna be
homeless and they raised millions and
millions Millions Callie Barry and this
one another one I have a big problem
with that
yeah I really do I really want to help
the source I don't want to [__] you
know I just believe that with politics
people get into politics either because
you love people yeah and you really want
to see the welfare of people but I think
some way agreed yeah I think so and
always that's that's our that's our
natural den we were whatever by Green
you know I at this point in my little
you when you become a comic
or anything when you dedicate your life
to an art there's some part of suffering
unless your family is well-off and they
pay your rent there's some part of
suffering and there's one day we're like
I'll even care about money though more
yep it has nothing to do with me I've
learned how to live without money for so
long that I would love to be a mayor of
a city to bring back what's been like
wait you know again I'm not here why
must I pay why must why must an American
parent pay anywhere from ah in this
neighborhood I don't know one who's in
the rest of the country anywhere from
180 to 300 week for your child to go to
date our camp in the summer 180 to 300 a
week per kid per kid for your child to
go not for nothing awfully North Bergen
New Jersey the most corrupt place on
earth and when I was growing up there
was a six-week program at the part that
you went to every day you play checkers
you throw frisbee as a [__] whatever
but they give you a lunch
they put a hose out in the afternoon so
you could with the spinner yeah jumped
in there and then to kick off him one
day a week you won on a trip you went to
a PA we play basketball at APA it was
with him that's practice when they made
the switch from New York to New Jersey
they took us to the Yankee game the bat
night and they'd give us like those
little prison sandwiches
it wasn't the [__] Beverly Hills
Hilton but it was something better
my daughter has nowhere to go in the
somnus yes right yes nowhere if I we
didn't put him in camp and my man about
paying not really I'm not cheap but
think about it there's no local park
where they could go to in what Hollywood
a Studio City and for six weeks I'm not
asking for all [__] eight weeks eight
there's a lot of kids out there and I
know my daughter is a pain in the ass
but a four week program from July 15th
August 15 were you taking the the Museum
of Arts down in Long Beach their
aquarium and all that
that's what they did I remember going to
summer camp one time in the Bronx
it was [__] phenomenal they took you
to the Bronx Zoo for three days you
walked around you saw a gorilla stabbed
another gorilla with a pocketknife and
[__] I mean that's the [__] that you'll
never forget you know it takes three
days to walk around the Bronx Zoo
yeah I don't know what it is now the
animals are now don't quote me on that
in the old days it was a three-day trip
to the bronze ooh even the churches in
New York I remember being in the Bronx
they had little activities activities
they would give you I remember the
orange with ham and cheese sandwich mock
with a juice in a little bag it was an
effort it wasn't [__] Chris right but
it was better than [__] nothing we
don't have that no more no but I wanted
it's like what you said where is all the
money going cuz there's so much money
that is put into the government yet is
still your friend you got to give them
$20 and make sure that he eats meuseum
there's a man who's building a circus
people getting shot at every other every
other turn where is the money
where is all this money you I mean that
Donald Trump was going to put billions
of dollars into creating a militaries
force in space what about here where's
the money going
I mean us I think New York and
California have the highest tax bracket
country yeah right and I mean I'll even
my wife just gives me an idea
about the taxes just an idea and you and
then you take a look grammar school and
the first day of grammar school they're
giving you a paper on what you gonna pay
what you gonna pay for donations are you
mmm-hmm you have to donate to the
grammar school yeah god that's cool look
at this two private schools in Studio
City all right there's two private
schools they love top-notch Notre Dame
and we're Felicia's kids work yeah my
son went to Campbell Hawk okay well yeah
it's dirty four G's and they tell you to
start you get like so when's like what
do you mean to start it's thirty four
G's and then throughout the year you got
a Duke yeah it's more than it's some
college it's just
no daughter get a scholarship to
Campbell yeah he with this he got a
scholarship and I had to I work I worked
two jobs
because my friends came together scoffs
yeah he got a partial scholarship and
then he's a [__] attorney now she's a
badass attorney now oh man big money and
but she got a scholar she's Spanish kid
yeah
you get scholarships there yeah cuz I
don't want him to go too but it was 34
grand and there he up throughout the
year the computer lab the [__] African
monkey exhibits [__] white people for
[__] Asian solidarity oh yeah they do
you all [__] month but you don't go to
private school
no but even in city school they we have
to Duke that so the thing is that the
valley has the best public schools yeah
so they have the elementary schools are
all really good schools but they operate
like privates like a private school so
no matter even if it is a public school
you're still paying for a lot of stuff
cuz they have the best they got the best
schools like Oliver well I sold the
pilot last year to Fox mm-hmm that was
in the pilot of me taken of the school
and there was one annoying Lane and
every time she sees you she would ask me
for a dupe every time I see the lady
it's always a Duke ask you straight up
in person the lady the lady that comes
up and says hey hi
yeah hi but August 14th will have
another fundraiser for moms and we're
asking for a minimum donation of 200
bikini cause we can end this right now
so act like the first six weeks the
sameness I grab my wife when I know I'm
not trying to be disrespectful pick an
amount give it to him and tell him to
leave us the [__] alone yeah and my wife
when she looked at everything she gave
in her mouth and she told me whether you
leave no then one day my wife went to
pick up the kidnap lady came up
we don't know where mercy isn't my wife
like told to get the [__] out of my face
so now the lady really don't [__] with
us from oh wow I just got to check out
of her cap my wife is like I'm back on
the tower right that's Duke and every
week yeah we every time we wanted it
it's a Wednesday you get dude don't be
an area go in second no shame no shame
and she'll go right she's got I think
that killed me the most is Lee can I
talk to you for a second
listen what happens on annual Kids Day
thing I know you have a hard time your
wife's not working we're looking for a
deuce but I need to throw on 50 yes yes
they don't even give you that Lee and
let's say why you're going hmm like were
you going let me see where I can fit in
my budget if they see a de don't just
leave you stand there I love you shirt
let me talk to you about what's going on
next Tuesday next Tuesday were having
the fundraiser and we advise that you
bring 200 cash and you said they going
she doesn't even have the class to close
me yeah like she couldn't even she
didn't have that like I got him for a
small 50 let me keep him over here ah
nice cuz I definitely got the small 50
like they just have know how very
Hollywood and it did it does it bother
me no does it make me a break me no it's
how they do it that's right it's how
they do it I've been duking out all my
life I know the Duke I know the Duke
look there's a look you give people that
means listen things are bad Duke me
something I ain't got a problem with
that but every [__] week you know it
ain't no more than 8:00 in the morning
if you're gonna dupe me Duke we at 2:00
in the afternoon
let me wake up at least the magazine's
they give you at paper they get you at
8:05 with a Duke you not even process in
your [__] coffee and they already
throwing numbers at your [__] you're
walking back like what the [__] just
happened
see like that you said something to me a
couple weeks ago Joey you said like you
think you took your daughter to Disney
or maybe was the hotel you took her to
for the fourth you know like listen was
expensive but I have no complaints look
it was a great time like that so that's
what gets me it's like when I pay five
six hundred a month for health and sure
and then I get a bill for for $6 from
the doctor just like the weird stuff
were you like I'm paying this should
take away all the annoyance and it just
doesn't as an American today without
hiding your emotions as an American
today I hope that you know that you get
[__] in yes absolutely
if you're an American today and you
don't think we'll feel like you think
you're on top of the world you're
getting [__] your phone company's
[__] what we fly we're getting [__]
in the ass you know when we do this I'm
not putting everybody's needs to make a
business everybody needs to make money
I'm not here against you making money
I've never been against a company making
money that's why you provide the service
but assume to be getting [__] didn't
last week they just came out with the
Marriott's we're hiding a $3 hidden
charge now gala you and me will go $3
they want to rob me for 382 that's fine
what did they do it to a million
customers here yeah yep that's it at 382
at 382 a million customers a year so you
know at every level when you're flying
you're getting [__] especially in
today's world and I love flying I love
traveling but I just it's a course to do
business and unless you're gonna take
your little scooter shut the [__] up you
know I don't bite my words that I was I
have agent I have a manager and I have a
lawyer they offer me this shitty ass
deal right a network show offers me this
[__] eyes deal and then I gotta run
it for them I said all right let's look
at this deal I gotta give you 10% I
gotta give you 10% I gotta give you 5%
and I got to pay 33 percent in taxes now
when you cut all of that out of there
how much money am I making nothing
so do you honestly think this is the
best deal for me would you take this
deal if it was you and that's that's
everything else that you do that's the
cable company that's the electricity we
pay for water they told us water is bad
we're paying for water
now they got oxygen bars all over we're
gonna be paying for air too cuz the
quality of the air is bad
you know how [__] up it is that you
got to pay for the Natural Resources
they've made everything a business I'm
for companies making money too we're not
for [__] us in the ass who's that
company no I said companies I said I'm
all for companies making them oh no I
have nothing against but they're abusing
now but right now as an American you
know whether you want to go to a Dodger
game a Lego game no matter what you know
you go to an event with your kids go to
Yankee game I've never even been to a
[__] Yankee game at the new stadium
yeah and people are [__] furious
people a few you know you can't think
about it no even on the airplane you
said it you gotta pay now for more
legroom right you got to pay for food
cuz they only give you snacks oh my god
I didn't know you had to pay for a seat
now yeah now you could be over here come
the overhead part you got to pay for
that I like when you when you go to
American Airlines
it says dole business or something
economy better coats and then whatever
and you look at coach and it says 482
and you're like wow 482 the boss Jesus
Christ and you click it 482 is the row
right next to the bathroom where people
don't shake the [__] dudes go [__] Yeah
right in that row that's a 480 to get
you yeah
now for an extra 60 250 you could sit in
row 18 a and for an extra 84 you could
sit in like 16 be disobey that you gotta
pay to sit and be emergency ow
you pay to be a hero because you have to
put you have to verbally agree that you
will you will help if there's an
emergency that way it comes up to she's
like are you gonna be able to help yeah
sure but you gotta pay that I'll open
the door and I'll push people on ya whop
you that something happens I'm pushing
this plane and I'm worried about I'm
taking my sleep apnea machine cuz I got
weed in that [__]
and I got floaties and a baggie and I'm
jumping off this [__] plane I'm not
worried about this fat get across yeah
go [__] yourself but pull it off the
plane now you gotta pay for that
get the [__] outta I'm opening this
thing up I'm using grandma's a parachute
now grab a Bible
[__] that dirty [__] I got [__] to do
people to see but you still gotta pay
for that oh [__] and they charge I got a
[__] email last week I'm not gonna
say what airline I don't know what they
were thinking
I don't know what they were thinking
they have a new service that you could
get there and bypass and I always knew
this is gonna happen
okay first they had okay so you buy a
plane ticket and if you buy a regular
ticket you gotta stand there like cattle
and away from the kids from your past so
I got out of jail come and shoot you at
the airport and they got in those zooms
like like a [__] what do you call
those things like the movies yeah yeah
what do they call they call something a
maze
Oh the main guy you stand in a maze so
when you get shot you all fall on each
other on the side you know and that's
what you pay for when you get a regular
ticket now when you get a first-class
ticket to give you the the fly through
which is never really fly through now if
you don't want to pay to take your shoes
off yeah you could pay for that service
and then they got came out with clear
will you just cut the line and put of
whatever that's 189 a year and unless
you fly 20 times or more a year that
comes up to eight nine dollars like
right I figured out I go for nine
dollars to cut through it's not a bad
deal but do you have to take your shoes
off we're clear sure
oh you do do you don't let you get when
I fly to LAX I don't think not no yeah
I've been flying out there so long they
know I'm no danger so they put me in
whatever that's called yes a pre-check
but when I fly back mm-hmm I gotta go
through the other line but now they got
a whole new day with a new one pop just
got a whole new dance for twelve hundred
and fifty dollars oh wow I could walk in
and not even see anybody
you check in you get a little cog
overhead they take you to the back
it's 1250 for you and a hundred for the
person that flies with you
1250 and how often now how many each
flight Purefoy [__] you oh my get it go
down quickly they don't have any
that's unbelievable thank you from you
check in a specific place so let's say
you Flom just I'm just saying this let's
say you fly an American to New York
that long flight you have to go to one
you have to have those priority and also
has one if you gotta fly from New York
from LAX to New York first class you
don't go to regular Delta you got a dump
the one they only fly to Boston or
something might dine there they cut you
and it's it's not bad they offer your
water they ask if you're hungry they
have like little chips and then like
bert bert belongs to the admiral club
that's why Bert gets lit he goes to the
Admiral club he's in there with
Sigourney Weaver drinking [__]
doubles talking about alien and [__] but
now forget that so let's say Americans
got the Admiral lounge you go you check
in a lady chase you put your little bus
and they have a different Admiral I like
[__] the Admiral laughs that's for white
punks I'm gonna take you to where like
Obama hangs in [__] you go there and
then when it comes down to your plane
they come get you and they zip you and
you get on the plane nobody knows
nothing it's twelve fifty per flight
there's two different packages well mr.
twelve fifty and one was for 750 per
flight and I'm like why would like I
knew this was coming I just didn't know
what level well that just shows you that
they don't really care about safety they
care about money that's right that
remember when you used to be able to
take your bottle of water on an airplane
now you got to throw it away and then
when you get on the other side a [__]
bottle of water cost $7 yeah so it
empowers they don't do that they wrap
your water up and they send it through
the machine they don't they don't make
you throw your water away and they got
attacks in Paris too it's just it's off
a profit they don't we've lost our minds
in this country it's become that becomes
so greedy is
not even about people anymore you're
right it ain't about your safety it's
about money
because what is taking the bottle of
water gonna do really like for real
let's be real about the bottle of water
right cuz you gonna you don't they don't
want you taking your own water they want
you to buy it on the other side it's I
was in Paris last year I've had a bottle
of water I was gonna throw it away and
the lady was like no no no no no you
don't do that they put it in a plastic
bag they check it and then they run it
through but it because that's that's
money we everything here is about money
it ain't about people even the dope that
like the laws like if I watch a
documentary I'm like smuggling stuff and
like the whole big thing is all we
caught this much amount even drugs we
found this like billions of dollars with
a coke they don't really care they care
that they're not getting it number what
they do the math they they double check
that math they [__] price okay yeah
they pump it up like the guys gonna sell
it on the street cause you know it's
such [__] anyway enough with the
political videos what's up with you
beautiful man I'm just making it another
day you know a thing about you as I see
out there doing your thing you don't
complain you always got a different
thing going on you always got a
different call them mine [__] yeah but
the more mind Fox you get yeah the
closer you are to your goal ma'am you
gotta go to a thousand mine Fox to do
anything you're still here you know the
last time I spoke to you you were on
Showtime to give you the decision yeah
and here you are with a Netflix tape
that's right yeah you have so many mind
[__] that people you know you ever wake
up on a Friday here well especially now
that we're getting old in Ewing and I'm
[__] tired yes yeah like what the
[__] that I do all week I didn't dig a
trench I didn't deliver [__] boxes
for FedEx you know I did a couple spots
I wrote I played with the kid I lifted
some weights why am I so tired you're
like oh maybe because I've been getting
mine [__]
[__] week from different [__]
ideas different scenarios and situations
maybe that's why I'm mine flock to you
they make that face than the lady who
tries to get you this I tell you it's
that time of year again it's Halloween
for midgets and this year for little
midgets we're gonna get them new hats
with new heads and you know yeah the
[__] leave me alone lady it's it drives
me [__] crazy but you know you get so
many mind [__] as a I say it would
[__] my kids a human being look at
them my [__] you got this weekend
yep you know now you don't know where to
go what's safe anymore what do you buy a
gun do you buy a [__] bulletproof
vest but you leave the house anymore I
mean there's so many [__] questions
now you know but in comedy
forget about oh man if you let them take
you to I get emails that would blow you
away that what you gonna be like huh oh
yeah and it's mind Fox a lot of them
were mine hey listen I got this you know
I had a guy last week let me let me send
you the first 56 pages of my script
listen there's people holding on to you
in case you below write so they give you
little little [__] you know what
I've been mind [__] enough for 20
years yeah how did you put together a
Netflix thing you know what I sat down
and I said what story do I want to tell
and I told the story of my family I told
the story of my family my grandma don't
know how did you get the Netflix Oh
Tiffany Haddish
Tiffany Haddish and I have been friends
for the last 11 years and we always talk
we always she's won that battle
that's like [__] that don't worry about
what they tell you go do what you got to
do right she would always tell me who
cares what they say you just keep
working it should say eventually
something's gonna pop you just got to
keep working but she would always be
like nobody's a victim we're not gonna
be victims here we did last comic
standing together and we made a pact
that whoever blew up would throw the
rope back and she blew up and she threw
the rope back without any hesitation
without she just kept her word
she said a man I'm doing this deal with
Netflix and part of my deal is that they
got to give a special to my people
because I believe in you and I think you
should have a special and she did it she
took a pay cut and she did it she just
kept her word that's crazy that the last
time Tiffany Haddish did the podcast
she was just regular Tiffany yeah yeah
five years ago up at the other office
but I tell you what Saturday
right no Thursday when I got to Chicago
and I was going to go to the room I was
on the phone with her she FaceTime me
she was she was falling asleep because
she's so tired she wouldn't get off the
phone until I was safe in the room she
said no no no I when I see you in the
room and you close the door I'll go to
sleep that's who she that was Thursday
that's who she still is to me
why did you shoot the special here and
at the Nate Holden theater and she she
produced it you see how the other girls
of the special April Macy's on it okay
Shantay Wayans this comedian named Tracy
Ashley who's one of the writers on the
lasso gee the show that she's on Marlo
who opens for her and Flame Monroe who's
transgender woman that Tiffany's known
for years who's been doing stand-up for
20 years I never got a break and Tiffany
was like you're gonna get a break today
how do you feel about it I feel good
about it very good did you work hard
before you shot it I did I talked to you
I did work really hard about it I put it
together and you're gonna hear the
stories of the Puerto Ricans and the
Cubans that raised me on that special
you know that that's that's what I
wanted to do I wanted to tell my story
about where I came from you know as
opposed to you know FedEx food and
airplane seats I really wanted to talk
about my uncle's who I adored because
you know that the you and I talked about
this I'm everything I am because those
undesirables love me those people stack
themselves up so I could get out of
where I was and that that's where I come
from I'm not ashamed of where I come
from I'm proud of it because those
creamy nylons though
Delon cuentas that they used to say of
my family they busted their asses so
that I could I could do well and they
were like it's not gonna happen for me
but it could happen for you so this is
what I'm gonna do so I wanted to pay
homage to damn my grandmother's shot the
blocker you know she she threw the drugs
she shot the drug dealers off the line
she was like see no sale wrong look
motto and she went to jail and her bata
or her sandals on and the judge sent her
home he was like she's a hero why did
you arrest her she is a hero that's what
I was raised in you know I wasn't raised
in at the a Campbell Hall like my son
you know I was raised watching people
make crack and doing whatever they had
to do to survive but I never looked down
on them and that was my story was this
special was I want to uplift these
people and I want people to know those
are human beings they did what they had
to do they had honor they had a cold and
they did everything that they could so
that I could have a better life and I
adore them
you know I adored them all so that's
what I did in my special my special was
that well it's funny because I grew up
and that [__] too
I know and it's uh it's weird when I
took from all of those people I took a
little piece of all of it yes they each
had one little good thing to offer
absolutely with criminals whatever they
did for a living and I would watch I'm
going to just take one little thing no
and I think about them this is the
problem this is my biggest this is
probably been my biggest problem that
I've never moved forward from that I've
never forgotten where I came from you
know and I know if I gotta [__] that's
why I love you that's what we're gonna
give a [__] about this or that mm-hmm
I'm not gonna come out here with some
[__] this is who I am this is where
I've been anything you're on the boat or
you're [__] not know and I've been
like that since day one and it's worked
and it keeps you going and get you know
what you you can you can sleep at night
I can sleep I can sleep at night I don't
and I did a lot of shitty things miss
things I sit at the time quite a while I
was talking with my wife two nights ago
we're talking about what I got we were
talking about before I got after I got
separated and the day that my ex-wife
took me to court and we had a lap like
the reason why I left Colorado and all
that stuff I said to her I'm not proud
of that day and all that day has kept me
up a lot because I knew the things I
said to her we're gonna ban me from
seeing that kid but I had to get him out
I have a Sam that's why I smacked the
boyfriend too because who cares if you
got two families
if you gotta come and then we're gonna
give me a lot you know you get three
felonies they give you a lot of
something call your whatever fellas her
life whatever the [__] and I think they
got on this my skin so much and I let
them but I said [__] I'm gonna get it
out I smacked to him and the whole thing
and I'm not proud of those days I'm not
proud of a lot of days this there's 25
days I wish I could [__] just light
on fire but you can't but you also know
though the thing about you is that
you're aware that that's [__] up [__]
and that's why you have a conscience
there are people who do [__] up [__]
and don't think it's messed up they walk
around the world thinking that's just
the way it is you have a conscious about
you that's your evolution and that's why
you help people and these people follow
you and they listen to you because it's
real and we got a you know like my mom
people used to talk [__] about my mother
so much cuz my mother was explosive
right like my mom was braiding my hair
one time and I kept saying I II I and my
friend would my mom is like a pasta like
what's wrong with your head and my
friend goes oh that's cuz miss patty
arrow was always hitting her in the head
with one of those fat pencils so my mom
goes to school the next day I'm standing
in line and I see my mom and I'm like oh
[__] yeah it's going down my god eat I
don't play that [__] right my mom was
like who's Miss pagli arrow and the girl
in behind me cuz that Miss Pagliano
right there she walks up to Miss pagli
arrow and she hits her in the head with
her shoe she said next time you want to
hit a little girl in the head with a
pencil you come hit me with a pencil
[__] and she hit her in there so they
rushed my mother to the office you know
I'm like all my mother's gonna go to
jail I'm going the mothers are like
that's unbelievable she's so tacky that
you know what my mom did that day first
of all she instilled in me the belief
that I could count on that [__] and
that [__] really had my back and at any
at any turn she would do whatever she
had to do to protect me from this white
lady who thought that she could pop all
the little Latino kids in the head with
a pencil and she's to treat us like [__]
but now after that day she never looked
at me again because she was scared of my
mother the other thing is I learned how
smart my mother is cuz when the
principal was like we're gonna call the
police she said great cuz we got two
reports to file and the police the the
principal was like what are you talking
about she said you can then arrest me
for assault and they're gonna arrest
that [__] for child abuse we both going
to jail today so go ahead and call the
police
cuz we got witnesses and they sent my
mother home they were like just just go
home miss Rodriguez we we just we'll
just handle it we'll just handle it but
I learned how smart she was my mom
didn't go to high school you know my mom
grew up in the streets figuring it out
but as a little girl I was like I can I
my mom became my hero
cuz I was like she will do anything for
me and not that's not so when I think
about people who look down on her and
would say oh look at how she's a tacky
as Puerto Rican woman with all these
kids or whatever my mom was a G and she
did what the best she could with what
she had and I bow down to her every day
I adore my mother with all her faults
that [__] is a writer and in my books
he's the best person on the planet then
I learned so much from her we're
supposed to learn from our moms were
supposed to take something from them and
I listen my mom was so tacky I wouldn't
even invited this [__] I 86 my mom at
the school event I had that I couldn't
have where she was that tacky but today
I wish I wouldn't have [__] 86 or
from those of my you know today I wish
she could come to a comedy show and act
like a [__] [__]
oh yeah I would scream and all that [__]
and we have people know why that listen
I'm [__] old we think my daughters
would be like when she's dead and I'm
sixty and I gotta go to the school
functions I'm the oldest [__] in
the room she's gonna feel weird you live
in Hollywood you're not gonna be the
oldest
normally Norman Lear has twins that are
25 and he's 75 yeah what a younger woman
yeah he is he has kids that range from
20 the twins or 20-something years old
to a daughter that's like 60 Christ yeah
you're not gonna be the old group not in
LA have you been acting it always I
haven't been I've been working on
developing a show I did I just did a
short film I did a short film with a one
of these actresses that actually she's
just got nominated for an Emmy which was
really cool and one of the guys from
Chicago Fire we we taped this this short
that I believe is gonna go to some you
know festivals but not as much as I'd
like to you know when you start your you
are respected as an actor but I have to
prove myself because yeah I'm not
respected as a [__] actor yeah are you
[__] kidding me man that I wish I was
I still get put in little trailers I
don't get about the booking days are
done the booking days a long job that
there's a lot of people that live the
struggle right now yeah how the people
were struggling a lot of people that
three years you know they always tell
you that everything comes to an end so I
don't feel bad for a lot of people a lot
of people I know had it good for [__]
nine years and this time they spent with
three hands they never thought the day
was gonna end and now they're living
their own hell yeah you know this is uh
this is a privileged woman you know like
I said to you five years ago a little
black girl sat across from me that have
been babysitting and bus dump in this
town 15 [__] years she'd been married
she was with the worst agents in town I
wish she left him everything changed for
her and God bless although she
remembered you that's what we were
blessed with that yeah we have a gift by
living here that we could hit the
lottery any day any time it's up to you
what do you wanna do you gonna hit the
lottery or you could sit there like a
c'mon P you gotta get out you gotta put
the effort in
how always [__] Tiffania busting her
ass so I've been doing stand-up for 11
years she's been doing it twice as long
as me so she's got I know for a fact 20
years for sure cuz I still remember
being with her in 2004 outside the Laugh
Factory with Ralphie May and her telling
the story so the things she had to do to
eat yeah that I would never repeat right
right that she said that she had to do
to eat yeah I'm over Ralphie going how
are you want cash today and her going
not too good at him bust about like 200
our bills and saying go get something
like that's how long I remember that
yeah I still remember her babysitting
for her agents kids yeah go up during
the daytime and she'd be on the floor
babysitting so when you see someone like
Tiffany Haddish you know that's what
keeps you here that's what keeps us here
yeah it sucks to live here you know kind
of bored
yeah the kids he did only peanuts and
there's no Spanish Puerto Rican kids
throwing sticks on the phone in the
street yeah but guess what
we're always alive like I said the last
time I saw you was at the wrap party for
I'm dying up here yeah then you were
talking to Showtime about a special yeah
look I don't know where get out of no
way that's why I tell people with this
career the easiest thing you to do keep
getting on set you've got mine stage
sheep right put the fireman's hat on yep
and let everything hit you in the head
and roll off and you just keep doing
spots hi you know they're doing a new
thing for whatever good I'm gonna keep
doing my spots I do three spots in ah
man what you're talking about
that's big ah you get hit with bricks
people throwing apples at you
your landlord they don't want you to fat
you're skinny you're too old you're too
short how many [__] stories there oh
you know you're an inch too tall you're
an inch too dark
you wear glasses you don't wear glasses
you're allergic to cats they hate you
with every [__] lie they can hate you
in here so you just put your head down
and keep getting onstage yeah that's it
they're gonna come to you in July the
entire they're gonna use you hey
well yeah I saw nobody mind the other
day 20 years ago and when I tell you
this conservatively 20 years ago this
guy was a [__] zero with eyes out
here nice guy the squeal of those guys
are they just sweet but you know if they
stood in the middle of a 4 or 5 a truck
wouldn't even hit him like if they said
this bastard stood in the third Lane
people would just whiz right through him
like like he has no luck this guy he
came out here and he gave it a walk and
they threw things at him and whatever
towards the end the kid from nine oh two
one oh approached and said listen I got
this movie and he was all excited and
then something happened he got a movie
in Taiwan so the project went down the
tubes do you know I talked to that kid
from 20 years ago the ad they and the
first thing he said to me was like I
know - when I was back on TV and that
guy called me he wants to do that thing
20 years later
so do you understand me we live in a
society where they think it happened in
a time and the mind Fox
you just have to learn how to all around
them but I did - a couple of months ago
and I was gone for 15 days right would
you go I went to Atlantic City I went to
I went to Miami for a day I went to saw
my mom and my nephew I went to Atlantic
City I did Borgata
I went from Borgata - I can't even
remember but I did 15 days I went to
Vegas for seven days and I went to
Atlanta and did the punchline I did 24
sets and straight no no no days off
within those 15 days of 24 sets my
career was projected to go to the next
level it was about seven mine [__] in
that whole time and what kept me saying
was being able to get on stage and then
that's when I came back nothing had
changed nothing have changed but the
only thing that changed was that I came
back a better comic because I was
on stage 24 34 days straight that's it
nothing's gonna change nothing nothing's
gonna [__] change you time changes
everything
yeah time every six month you just keep
digging yeah he'll every six months you
pop your head up what that what's that
thing that happened in February 3rd
Groundhog Day you're a grandpa that's
all you are every six months you pop
your head up hey we need you for this
okay if not back down back down and keep
[__] digging but now III don't want
to sound biased but I think that a lot
of times that has a lot to do with being
Latino like we have this we take this
work ethic with us there's this
immigrant approach to work where it's
like you you see Latinos they go to work
like my mom would because I'll tell my
mom Oh mommy I was talking to too you
know
Showtime blah blah and my mama's without
yeah but do you got your rent money she
don't give a [__] about none of that
she's like promises she goes me huh I
put on my Savi anything I keep every day
you're gonna hear promises all the time
you just guaranteed is you showing up
you can't guarantee them to show up so I
think that we do that like we just have
this mentality about you know like my
mom my mom is like the father and and
coming to America when he walked in the
barber shop he's like hello my name is
King Joffrey I'm the king of Zamunda
and the guy was like yeah all right take
a seat it's eight people in front of you
that's how my mom is I feel like mommy I
Netflix and I think she'd be like
Netflix gonna flame up all that I that's
all beautiful Deana handle De Niro
Potter I love Billy cuz I don't want you
to be on the street that's all she cares
about is like the basics and the
fundamentals the problem that we have
here the problem that we have as
Americans humans is that we get
detracted
if I look at my life when I've got
distracted yeah when you're in this town
you either drink the [__] juice we
don't drink the juice the other day I
was talking to our mutual friend Nick
the door mm-hmm he says hey do you see
the trailer for the Irishman it looks
pretty good I go give us a [__] are you
making any money from me because that's
why I love talking to you because you
know how to sit through [__] oh yeah
the Avengers Oh what and I sat next to a
guy with a dog why would you be in the
Avengers you're a comic why would you
like if you concern yourself with all
little things along the way you're not
gonna get that you call you go crazy you
go crazy oh yeah if you go crazy it has
nothing to do with you it's got nothing
to do with you there's nothing you could
do you know if right now if Tiffany
didn't do that show and Jane Smith did
it and you sent the tape like you
usually do the Netflix makes your
showcase and they make you showcase
again and they call you and they go we
gave it to a Chinese drum kit that's all
those [__] fountain wontons up in the
end get some you know you didn't get
that opportunity somebody just called
you gave it to you yeah somebody
ignorant would say yeah but she's
friends with Tiffany Haddish no I've
been here banging out for 20 years you
dumb [__] and even an old dog gets a
warm spot on the sidewalk eventually
yeah if you put the work in I don't know
what your future is gonna be right I
don't know what my future is gonna be
but I knew one thing if I put the work
in and I what the battery mind knowing
that I did the best I could
today I'm good with that that's it
whether you starting a podcast whatever
the [__] you're doing
I just want you to remember that you're
doing it for today yep and as long as
you know that today you did the best you
could be right today I did the best I
was the best like to be at what I do
today I did three sets I lifted I ain't
good I sent my niece I helped her out
with her problem I [__] did this I
did that you know it doesn't matter what
happens successful come your way
eventually because you put the [__]
time in I believe that it's a true
outliers I've seen it I've seen it here
yeah I have seen it I have seen it in 22
years yeah I've seen the people who came
in everything was a joke well my friends
gonna help he's friends with Robin
Williams that's right you still gotta
get on stage tonight what are you
talking about yeah until you are you
[__] getting an Oscar
there's no nights off last night I took
to [__] that what happened was I took
the 50 if you know is we don't smoke
party in what happened because we had a
we had to do a better job so I took the
50s and I put them with the hundreds and
I mixed them one landlord so I didn't
know what I was eating so I just took
three of them list oh they could have
been 300 milligrams it could have been
150 milligrams anywhere or it could have
been 250 milligrams it could have been I
didn't know what it was and I could not
watch TV my wife went to bed did I not
call you a 12:30 last night and I was
writing a bio yeah [__] send an email
but gasps oh no I'm productive every day
absolutely
I'm productive every day just cuz I'm at
the Comedy Store no I'm doing so no but
I mean you took the edibles and you were
oh that's what I do my become the lady
at the PTA I do my best work I'll call
your house [__] at midnight and then
also at 6:00 in the morning highs [__]
he takes a bong hit and he's like why
are you up already it's it's 7:30
working well what were you talking you
know what I look forward every morning
to your tweet I don't for that tweet
that the daily tweets yeah that needs to
be a book
oh no this morning I thought about I
didn't really want to tweet too hard
because of what mm-hmm I just wanted to
say that it's a beautiful day to be
alive don't you for [__] grant no my
favorite was the other day when you said
they're not giving out charity sorry
that's the truth everybody wakes up
thinking today's the day yeah I was one
of those guys the bartender's that put
me in a movie really cuz I thought if I
bartend that somebody would come and put
me in a movie
others gonna be cute and crack jokes
what kind of bar and somebody put me in
a movie okay there's no way about acting
class right right don't worry about that
don't worry about putting the work in
just you know do it is that you do and
you'll be fine
no I stripe whether it's Latino work
ethic whatever work ethic I got it from
I saw people who were stand-ups got a
little bit of a career and for some
reason stop doing stand-up yeah and then
when everything stops you try to come
back and now those people you were with
they're a foot away from you you used to
behead bad with them but you completely
stopped that's why you never stopped
that's right never stop I can't go to do
jitter every day no more every other day
but I go every Sunday Hank or every
Sunday and you meet up with in my face
and yesterday I got [__] beat up
yesterday I can't go every day don't
know you have a meetings writers and
should that but guess what I go every
Sunday you know if I go twice so we can
go twice away do you have to as a
stand-up as an artist you have to keep
doing your thing yeah that's why I hate
when people go away I had to get a day
job well [__] if you really love what
you like
you'd be doing that at night or you'd be
getting up at what time you got to be at
work ten what happened to sex is doing
where your passion I'm gonna tell you
something when I hear people tell me
these stories but I just had to tell
somebody this the other day my daughter
used to swim right swim practice is that
5:00 in the morning at Pierce College
and she went to school at El Camino
which is in Woodland Hills I lived in
Sherman Oaks I would get off stage and
go home at one o'clock in the morning I
would get up at 4:00 I would take my
daughter to swim practice I was sleeping
the car while she practice then I would
drive her to school and then I would
drive to work at Edward Jones where I
worked and I would work there for eight
hours I will come home I will cook
dinner I would do homework with them and
then I go do stand-up and then I do it
all over again so when I hear people
tell me that that they don't they got
why I want to do my dream I was like you
got to put the hours in you got
there's no there are no excuses I could
sit around and cry and say oh I'm a
single mother I don't get child support
Bob what the hell is that gonna do that
ain't gonna put a steak fish on the
table
I don't have time for that now he's in
jail he really can't do you know exactly
the opened up your [__] mouth
what are you gonna do you got no
driver's license you got no money cuz
you put this [__] come watch on them and
now you gotta work no I think I tipped
my hat off the Elat ADA you wouldn't
have a Netflix special if you haven't
been putting in the [__] time all
these years well that means a lot they
gave you a little window with Last Comic
Standing you busted through it you never
look back you know everybody thinks at
all I need a push no there's a window
there's some day you know wow he's a
burglar so I'd walk down the streets
looking for a window that was a burglar
I would walk down the streets looking
for a window Oh first of all I know that
everybody 80% of people don't close the
bathroom window they open it and close
it to release the steam especially woman
they don't put the lock back on because
when they go to put makeup on they can't
have moisture in the [__] room so I
know that I know that my percentages
were higher if I went to a bathroom
window you know what the chances are on
me fit into a bathroom window a lot of
bathroom windows are small they're over
the tub you got a land head first on the
tub trust me
I landed a couple times on my neck
breaking that the drug dealer houses
going to the bathroom window but we're
all looking for a window where they were
uncommon an artist the window is open
it's not going through the window is
what you're gonna do on the other side
that's right that's right that's you
know I love when people go oh well Joe
is where he's at because Rogen help them
really know if that's what you think
you're just an ignorant [__]
that's been making excuses for yourself
all your life that's right
open oh rogon open the window for me he
could have closed it oh I could have
gone through it and done my own work and
that's exactly what I did
you know people windows open up for you
you have to go through that window and
know what you're gonna do when you're
two feet land on that other side I'm not
that's what this town is about open
windows that's a that's what life is
about an opportunity on the open window
well we don't want to go there and work
for eight bucks an hour I'm gonna start
as a car wash it but what you didn't
know is you started on Monday and the
following Monday the general manager
quit which meant everybody bumped up and
if you would have taken that job you
have been at 12:50 now you follow me
yeah so nothing happens if you don't try
and listen I worked at Edward Jones
which is a an investment brokerage for
many years but in between that because
they got so rough I used to work at
Federal Express and my shift was 4:00 to
6:00 a.m. and 4:00 to 6:00 p.m. that's
the beat they're like an entry shift and
I will go in the morning and I would on
the belt with the packages and then I
will go back and I was still doing
stand-up and I still had a job and I
still had two kids and there were no
excuses because that's just that's just
life you know and if you're sitting
around waiting on somebody to give you
something you're gonna even be bitter
you're gonna sit and wait for a long
time because everybody's trying to get
theirs you know you're not on the top of
the list of somebody else's priorities
and we just sit around waiting on other
people to give a [__] you got your own
platform you look what you did you went
and built it you want to built it listen
I knew that if you put your head down
yes state consistent mmm-hmm and stuck
to the plan because a man without a plan
you got nothing you stuck to the plan
you got a half-hour Netflix special out
of it
let's who god knows what's next so how
was your Netflix special didn't make a
difference in your business yes it did
yeah it did I didn't do a good job as I
wanted to on what I'm the special my I
didn't think I could I did as well as I
did but it did make a difference you
know yeah
it's it's not that it made a difference
it's all the things you do around them
mine you know you could shoot a movie
and let it release September 25th or you
could write a book to go with that movie
god forbid your buddy you get in it and
awesome next thing you know the episode
you did is coming out the movie comes on
the 25th so and the TV show you did with
him is on the 18th and then you release
a podcast and you release a blog and
next thing you know it's like oh my god
Joe is that busy no he's not that busy
he just made everything come out all at
one time right everything was prepared I
learned that 1987 Richard Gere put on
one of the worst movies he could ever
put out it was a great movie it's an
Academy Award what a movie asked me the
one with Andy Garcia when he [__] his
wife oh oh yeah that was uh that was raw
Diane Lane yeah roar which would no no
no wasn't with the Hamlet that was the
one he did he didn't move me in 87
internal affairs Oh internal affairs
well he was [__] evil and he rose that
mexican off the balcony he's at the
[__] just [__] everybody's wife and
his part of his wife his bum her in the
ass when you left that movie you're like
[__] what you get yeah he had just won
an Academy Award for officers and
gentlemen
and then that came out like maybe two
years later or something he came all the
time you see internal offense that's a
scene where he goes to see his ex-wife
he goes to pay child support he's like
are you busy right now but she's like no
we're just gonna do laundry he just
opens the bedroom door get in this like
the [__] he's a dog but what did he do
he made sure pretty women came out three
weeks later yeah he ended up smelling
like a [__] rose
he ended up smelling like a [__]
wrong look at the release dates from
whatever to whatever it was just a
couple months apart but it was perfect
he did he did that perfectly in your
mind you think he's busy he just made
everything I got all that watch man but
no I'm very proud of you either
you know that that means a lot to me
come on Uncle Joe listen I would the
brothers never college I wouldn't have
put you on the podcast if I do it
there's so many people out there that
have faith in the father and things
don't happen so now they they they think
oh well if I do three podcast I'll be
back what was the difference
internal affairs came out January 12th
and pretty woman came out March 23rd
little [__] you think you're dealing
with joy bananas so [__] obvious from
the [__] Street that was that was
brilliant that move you know but you
wouldn't be on the podcast I don't deal
with people were faking the [__] does I
know you my my [__] blows up every week
emails and 80 comics don't wanna be huh
I look at this social media ain't doing
[__] I look at that website looks like
somebody blew it the [__] up I don't
have a podcast that they do they don't
let nobody know so you're doing
everything 50 percent so I gotta do the
whole work Lee you can't come on the
podcast but you my friend
I'm always hearing good things about you
ah thanks you get prettier every time
with and we put you in the hospital one
day when somebody goes to the hospital
for uncle Joey you're it with me that's
an it say a word you shut your mouth you
need to say nothing nothing what did you
take I don't know nothing I went to a
Chinese restaurant you don't know
nothing you know nothing about drugs
your son called me what you give my
mother
don't worry about it yeah but you know
we don't we don't we don't do that like
we've never turned on our own what's the
name of this specialist so that it's
just my name they all have our all of
our specials our names but it's
definitely have this president and then
I thought nobody goes and it comes out
next August 13 which is Tuesday and next
week with you tweeted out retweeted for
you thank you and where can they find
you at funny I got calm that's my
website funny AIGA calm and at funny a
tidy a you got a what your dates are
there
oh my daytime in it no if my home I
listen to the geez you know all right
double check so they go there they want
to see you there's no [__] proms
people come to my shows because they
heard quite a few of them couple people
have hit me back and said thank you for
turning me on Dana I know that you not
the other part either will you be this
weekend this weekend I'll be a hyenas
and Dallas okay next weekend I'll be at
Mohegan Sun in Connecticut oh [__]
that's a good [__] joy I will be this
weekend Friday night the Lincoln Theater
in DC and Saturday night I am in the
Borgata both shows are sold out so I'll
catch you [__] next time next
time you should have planned that and I
hate having the shows in Jersey because
I won't get to see my friends so I
couldn't a - I want to say I'm with my
friends afterward but I'll be walking
around the [__] casino doing my thing
we can't smoke dope there so I'll just
be [__] playing blackjack like I did
last time I lost 40 bucks and I stopped
look at this anyways the church is
brought to you by zip recruiter listen
you know how challenging and hiring is
right it's hard to find qualified
candidates it takes a long time too many
applications too many applicants but
guess what zip recruit it makes it easy
alright there's one place and that's zip
recruited comm / Church hiring used to
be hard we all know that multiple job
site stacks of resumes confusing review
process
but today hiring could be easy and you
only got one place to go to get it done
zip recruiter town / Church zip
recruiter send your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there as applications come in
zip recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match the zip recruit
is so effective that four out of five
employers will post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate through the site
within the first day the G what I said
one day you want to be in business with
zip recruiter right now the church
family could try out zip recruiter for
free Joey what are you talking about
free free
free by going to this exclusive app
dress you ready grab a pen
zipper cool calm / Church that zip back
Runa calm / shirt CH you are CH remember
zip recruiter sends your job to over a
hundred of the web's leading job boards
and they don't stop there the zip
recruiter is the way to go to find a
quality candidate so again zip recruiter
comm slash Church CH you are CH zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire
listen don't sweat hair loss this summer
do some way you still got a little bit
of it what 60 what you don't know is
that 66 percent of men lose their hair
by the age of 35 let me ask you this why
the hell do guys go the weird solutions
or do nothing when they could turn to
medicine and science you let me know
well listen gotas for hems coms for hims
fo r hims dot-com a one-stop shop for
hair loss skin care and sexual wellness
for men well known generic equivalents
to name-brand prescriptions to help you
keep your hair alright hims connects you
with real doctors and medical grade
solutions to treat hair loss no snake
wall pills a gas station counter
supplements prescription solutions
backed by science no waiting room
no awkward in persons doctor visits save
hours by going to for hems calm it's
easy you answer a few questions
the doctor will review it and they can
prescribe you what you need stop
worrying about sun block on that spot of
thinning hair and do something to help
stop hair loss and help promote hair
growth products are shipped discreetly
and directly to your door now do me a
favor order now the church family gets a
trial month two hymns for a listen you
ready grab the plane for five hours
that's right I said five hours while
supplies last go to forums comm slash
Church slash Joey
that's for hems comm slash Joey and get
five hours a trial
month for five hours starting today
while supplies last again go to forums
comm / Joey that's for hims dot-com /
Joey I want to thank ADA Rodriguez thank
you for having me I love you I want to
thank the crazed killer
I want to thank zip recruiter I want to
thank Williams for hims but most
importantly I want thank you
[__] for always supporting us
and having our back we'll be back
Thursday morning tip-top Magoo ready to
[__] rock again ghost ate a
funny I de la di de dot-com a to either
a the fellated 13 no and august 13th a
Netflix special comes I ready for Freddy
I'm [__] Netflix with my girl Tiffany
Haddish I love you [__] have a
great week and we'll see you soon in two
days stay black kick this meal Lee